Casey nice that represents to most
people I think what's possible through a
career on YouTube he's had a successful
short film career lane did a
multi-million dollar acquisition from
CNN for his company and is insanely
popular so how did my site get here
after being a high school dropout I
think if you'd asked him he'd say what
he had said a million times already it
was a lot of work
nice that's hardly the only one doing
this he's part of a growing trend of
people that have been selling the Silver
Bullet of success to be the simple
answer here is very simply that you need
to you need to work harder and faster
there's really nothing else planned like
this idea of working harder is always
the answer has an almost frat boy
following to it and it's hard to miss
why it's so appealing
it's an athlete's mentality hard work
there's a real drama and excitement to
the struggle and everything's always
within your control but is that all it
took for Nystedt to go from broke to
here I don't think so
hard work was necessary for Nystedt
success but not sufficient success is
not solely a function of hard work it's
highly dependent on the quality of the
career opportunity or idea that you're
pursuing think of the millions of people
working minimum-wage jobs in America who
are working hard sometimes 80 hours a
week just to stay afloat for these
people it's not about hard work but if
hard work isn't enough how did my step
become so successful so let me explain
in the book outliers Malcolm Gladwell
analyzes people who excel at their craft
he finds that good timing plays a big
role in why many people become
successful even Bill Gates he talked
about one of the secrets to Bill Gates
success was that he had access to a
computer that he could practice coding
on years before most people did so Bill
Gates literally had thousands of hours
of programming practice under his belt
before anyone else got started and his
competitive advantage positioned him
perfectly take advantage of the PC
revolution that started when the Altair
computer came out in 1975 well just like
the computer revolution there has been a
filmmaking revolution since YouTube came
out too
five and like gates nice I've got a
critical head start in filmmaking before
most would-be youtubers had even picked
up a camera see nice that first got into
professional filmmaking with a guy named
Tom sacks in 2001 he developed a lot of
his file here and he continued honing
his craft of filmmaking with several
videos and an HBO special so that later
in 2010 when he fully embraced the
YouTube space his content was noticeably
more refined and substantive than his
peers and this is part of a magic of
watching nice that his style seems to
come fully formed right out of the gate
whereas most youtubers have to find
their voice within the first few years
nice that had already found his would
nearly a decade of practice under spell
so with this in mind the final pieces of
story becomes Bobby oh nice that's rise
to be YouTube's favorite blogger when
nice that entered the vlog space in 2015
he was joining a group of bloggers with
little film experience which makes it
clear why nice that's quality stands
above the rest
it's also why you see comments like this
on his vlog all the time it's a bit like
watching a professional baseball player
play in a high school game he just had
way more experience so nice does timing
with filmmaking was perfect had he
started filmmaking earlier he might have
been too far into a career to switch to
YouTube which is why most career
filmmakers missed the YouTube boat and
had he started later he'd just be
another vlog or trying to figure out his
style but what happened was the
combination of the right idea the right
work ethic and the right timing that's
what made Casey nice that successful
okay so why does it matter the nice that
somewhat under sells the role luck
played in his success luck and all that
other education all that like it's not
even in the same pie chart I think what
bothers me is a lot of people see nice
that I want to become filmmakers like
him and are told that work because the
only thing that's standing in their way
but this isn't actually true
what made nice that go from a small
indie filmmaker to the cover of GQ
magazine in less than two years with
bringing nearly 15 years of professional
film experience into a field where most
people were total amateurs but that has
changed the idea of being a blogger is
worth a lot less now now that there are
hundreds of people occupying the
space and producing regular content and
their contents getting better and I
guess I just want to tell anybody with
the hunger to be successful that the
next my step probably won't be a vlogger
it will be someone who utilizes a timely
competitive advantage to dominate the
market space or something like that I
don't know I'm just a youtuber and as a
youtuber it's just a part of the video
where I tell you for the millionth time
what you already know that you can
subscribe and like and watch another
video if you want so yeah thanks for
watching I'll see you guys next
Wednesday with another video